[Music]
[Music]
but what am I do
the Senate will come to order the clerk
will read the communication to the
Senate
Washington DC April 9 2022 the Senate
under the provisions of rule 1 paragraph
3 of the standing rules of the Senate I
hereby appoint the Honorable Roy Blount
a senator from the state of Missouri to
perform the duties of the chair
signed Chuck Grassley president pro
tempore a majority leader I ask consent
to be recognized notwithstanding the
order for a pro forma session today is
there objection without objection
majority leader our nation continues to
battle the coronagraphs pandemic more
than 400,000 Americans have tested
positive nearly 15,000 have lost their
lives nurses doctors and EMTs are
fighting this disease literally day and
night and important public health
measures are creating an economic
catastrophe this morning we learned that
six point six million more Americans
filed for unemployment in just the last
week that means mr. president more than
16 million Americans have lost their
jobs in only the last three weeks a
tragedy that is hard to even comprehend
as one journalist put it we're facing a
health care crisis with an economic
crisis strapped to its back
that is why two weeks ago the Senate
passed the largest rescue package in
American history the bipartisan cares
act follow more than two trillion
dollars into bold programs to help
households fund hospitals and health
care providers and keep paychecks coming
before we adjourn I said the Senate
would stay nimble and prepare to react
quickly as the legislation came online
so much better that's why we
today much of the Kozak is still being
implemented but one key program one key
program is already up and running
it's the Paycheck protection program
from chairman Rubio chairman Collins
senator Cardin and Senator should end it
gives small businesses emergency capital
so that workers can keep getting
paychecks instead of pink slips just a
few days after the program open for
business 100 billion dollars in loans
have already been committed that is 30
percent of the total funding spoken for
and just the first few days actually
that's very good news it means this job
saving program is attractive to small
business employers can access it but it
also means we need more funding and we
need it fast
soon I will ask unanimous consent to
increase the funding for the Paycheck
protection program to a new total of six
hundred billion dollars I'm not talking
about changing any policy language that
both sides have already negotiated
together several weeks ago I'm literally
talking about deleting the number 350
and writing 600 in its place let me say
that again but I'm talking about making
any policy changes we're literally
changing the number 350 to 600 that's
all this we're suggesting here today
that by definition is a clean bill I
want to add more money to the only part
of our bipartisan bill that is currently
at risk of running out of money so I was
surprised to see this simple proposal
met uneasily by the Democratic
leadership the distinguished Democratic
leader and the Speaker of the House
sought to use this crucial program to
open broader negotiations on other
topics including parts of the cares Act
where literally listen to this mr.
president
literally no money's gone out the door
yet
no money has gone out the door yet the
Democratic leadership has suggested they
may hold Americans paychecks hostage
unless we passed another sweeping bill
that spends a half a trillion dollars
doubling down on a number of parts of
the cares Act including parts that have
not even started to work yet the country
cannot afford unnecessary wrangling or
political maneuvering treating this as a
normal by part of normal kind of
partisan negotiation could literally
cost Americans their jobs we were in a
situation right now where passing a bill
means either unanimous consent or a
voice vote everyone knows everyone there
is zero chance that the sprawling
proposal that our democratic friends
have gestured towards could pass either
chamber by unanimous consent this week
no chance
and the president's already indicated he
would not sign it country needs us to be
nimble nimble to fix urgent problems as
fast as we can to be able to have
focused discussions on urgent subjects
without turning every conversation into
a conversation about everything without
turning every conversation into a
conversation about everything we need to
patch holes as we see them and keep
moving forward together everybody in the
Senate voted to send historic funding to
hospitals and health care providers
everyone supports funding hospitals I'm
in favor of even more funding for
hospitals and providers down the line
I've been talking to a number of them as
I'm sure our colleagues have over the
last couple of weeks but certainly we
need to see the fixing the existing
funding began to work before we know
what additional resources may be needed
I've been urging secretary azar to push
this money on to the front lines as soon
as possible I'm glad tens of billions
are going to go out tomorrow there's
only one part of the cares Act that is
already already at risk of exhausting
its funding right now only one part of
the cares Act is at risk of exhausting
its funding right now the Paycheck
protection program we're asking small
business owners across America to place
their faith in us we're asking them to
keep workers on payroll because Congress
the Treasury and the SBA will have their
back we must not fail them my colleagues
must not treat working americans as
political hostages this does not have to
be nor should it be contentious we don't
have to divide along the usual lines so
soon after we came together for the
country - my Democratic colleagues
please please do not block emergency aid
you do not even oppose just because you
want something more do not block
emergency aid you do not oppose just
because you want something more nobody
believes this is the sentence last word
on kovat 19 we don't have to do
everything right now
in fact our posture of needing unanimous
consent does not even permit us to try
to do everything right now we cannot
play games through this crisis let's
pass more non-controversial funding for
Americans paychecks let's do it today
and then let's continue to work together
with speed and bipartisanship we will
get through this crisis together
now mr. president I ask unanimous
consent the Senate proceed to the
immediate consideration of the bill at
the desk I further ask that the bill be
considered Brad a third time and passed
and the motion to reconsider be
considered made and laid upon the table
is there objection
object the senator from Maryland Thank
You mr. president let me just clarify
some of the issues that the majority
leader pointed out I'm afraid that this
unanimous consent is basically a
political stunt because it will not
address the immediate need of small
businesses in the legislation that we
have passed and let me clarify that the
majority leader indicated that the PPP
the paycheck protection plan is on our
money it hasn't 30% has been committed
it hasn't been yet released but there
are programs under carrots Act that have
run out of money the idol program the
emergency disaster relief alone program
which provides funds for businesses and
we've allowed businesses that have been
affected by the coronavirus to follow
those those claims that has run out of
money there and I'll give you the
numbers in a few moments and the grant
program that's included and cares that
up to $10,000 we're a small business can
get a grant from the Small Business
Administration is out of funds they need
money today in order to process
applications the SBA doesn't need money
today to process the paycheck protection
program the Paycheck protection program
was negotiated in good faith by senator
Rubio senator Collins senator Shaheen
and myself and we're very proud of that
program it's working very well it's a
good program we strongly support it it's
bipartisan
but this unanimous consent request was
not negotiated there was no effort made
to follow the process that we could get
that's done so it won't get done it's
not going to be enacted and I'm the
majority leader knows that so what
Democrats are prepared to make clear and
support every small business that's
eligible to receive the Paycheck
protection plan we're going to support
their applications being received
process and fully funded and we will put
as much money as needed to make sure
that every small business can
participate that's eligible in that
program the UC does not affect that
today but what the UC leaves out is
where small businesses need help today
from the United States Congress so so
yesterday we had an opportunity to find
out the numbers as the majority of the
leader pointed out we've got to get this
right there's six point six million more
uninsured today as we learn to put the
current numbers we got to protect small
businesses to protect their payroll and
that's what with our plans do so
yesterday we were informed by the SBA
that as the majority leader indicated we
have got a hundred billion dollars that
have been processed now that has not
been distributed yet mr. president
hasn't been distributed in large numbers
because of documentation problems and
know your your customer rules have
prevented some of these funds a lot of
these funds a majority these funds is be
released but today applications are
being processed
tomorrow applications are going to be
processed that day after that
applications are going to be processed
because we provided 350 billion and at
this moment we're at about a hundred
billion we're going to probably provide
more money for that but where is the
urgency as far as the small businesses
are concerned so let me go over those
one the emergency grant program this is
a program that's where grants are
offered by the Small Business
Administration you don't have to have a
banking relation with a commercial bank
in order to get these loans very very
popular 3.8 million requests have come
in in regards to these loans 3.8 million
representing 372 billion dollars of
loans but here's the problem
we've only authorized 7.3 billion
dollars of loans under the program
that's why we are suggesting that if you
add another 50 billion dollars you can
you can authorize another 300 billion
dollars of loans under the emergency
really disaster relief program because
today if you've requested that loan
today and you requested the average
amount that's being requested and you
have to show need in this program you
got to document the need that you that
the disaster has affected your viability
as a business the average loan is two
hundred thousand dollars that's what
they're requesting guess how much money
the SBA
can can issue today fifteen thousand
dollars
that's an urgent need that we should
deal with today and we're prepared to
deal with it but there's a second
program for smaller by the way smaller
businesses participate in these programs
more so than the PPP program there's a
second program it's a grant program up
to ten thousand dollars our working
group bipartisan group recognized that
there are some businesses that they're
desperate need of cash immediately these
loans are processed in three days and
we've had so far
requests for the grant program 3.5
million small businesses have requested
funds totaling our requests for 11
billion dollars on a sliding scale
doesn't even give every small business
ten thousand dollars how much money did
we appropriate ten billion dollars SBA
cannot release those funds in three days
because they don't have the money to do
it the you it you see by the majority
leader does not provide that money so
that those small businesses can get that
cash that's not provided now we got that
information yesterday maybe the majority
leader didn't have it but we can tell
you they can't issue those grants and
that's under the cares act and that is
out of money so I've also tell you some
stories we've heard in Maryland I've
heard it all over the country I've heard
from small businesses that they went to
their back
in order to participate in a PPP loan
and they were told that they didn't have
her credit card so the bank wasn't going
to write the loan or they hadn't had a
previous loan with that Bank so if banks
not gonna write the loan we've heard
from some community banks that they're
out there they own you can handle
existing customers they can't do
additional customers at this point so
we've heard from Rural Bank or wrote a
small businesses they can't find lenders
who will write these notes we've got to
do a better job what did we find out
yesterday of the total 7a lenders that
are out there today about 90% were
certified before the cares Act we've
only increased our numbers by about 10%
that's not enough we can't reach these
underserved communities we got to do a
better job and reach these underserved
communities so that a small business
that doesn't have that type of
relationship with a bank can still
participate in the paycheck protection
plan this you see does nothing at all
about that issue nothing at all about
that the urgent issues are not dealt
with in this you see so that's why the
process of negotiating allowing us to
come together and figure out what's the
best way to move forward will result in
us actually getting something done to
help the small business community and
and their other urgent needs and my
colleague senator Van Hollen it's going
to talk about some of these but the
health care issue he and my colleague
and I participated in numerous
conference calls over the last ten to
two weeks I'm sure my other colleagues
have done the same and we've heard from
our health care providers that they're
ready to close the doors they need
immediate help and a lot more than 100
billion that's been provided we talked
to our governor yesterday he's a head of
the National Governors Association David
requested five hundred billion dollars
they need money their revenues are down
we know we didn't do right for the
District of Columbia we know we didn't
do right for smaller communities we can
need to correct that now because they
can't stay in business today it's urgent
and the UC does nothing to help in that
regard so mr. mr. president I'm
good I'd like to allow my colleague from
Maryland who I believe has a reservation
also and then and has a UC request of
his own senator from Maryland Thank You
mr. president reserving the right to
object this is an unfortunate moment for
the United States Senate you know we
came together on a bipartisan basis just
a very short time ago to pass the cares
Act it passed here 96 to nothing that
followed two other bipartisan efforts
that came out of the house passed the
Senate were signed by the president
again overwhelming support and yet today
we see from the majority leader a
complete political stunt here on the
floor of the United States Senate
something that does not have bipartisan
support something that is going alone
take it or leave it and totally violates
the spirit all of us have been working
on during this crisis where we were able
to come together in the United States
Senate and the House of Representatives
with the White House to on three prior
occasions pass legislation in a way that
addressed the issues that are important
to this country and yet today we have
this situation where the majority leader
knew full well that there was not
agreement and consensus on moving
forward with this proposal that's why
we're here today this was in fact
designed to fail designed as a political
stunt it's actually not the first time
we've seen this you may recall that just
before we came together and passed the
Kerr's act 96 to zero the majority
leader came to the floor of the Senate
back then and tried to ram through an
unfinished product while negotiations
were going on between Secretary minuchin
and Democrats in the House and the
Senate to try to finalize the bill and
that actually caused unnecessary
the way but the majority leader came
before then tried to ram it through it
didn't work then and it's not going to
work today so I would ask the majority
leader and I think all of us would to go
back to trying to address these issues
the way we address them in a successful
manner before and I'm going to shortly
propose an amendment that addresses some
of those concerns an amendment to the
Majority Leader's proposal but I'd like
to address some of the issues first and
my colleague senator Cardin has
addressed many with respect to small
businesses first of all he pointed out
that the one program to help small
businesses is actually really run out of
money as the emergency loan and rant
program but let's talk about the PPP
program this is a really important
program to incentivize small businesses
and nonprofits to keep employees on the
payroll and allow them to help keep the
lights on pay fixed costs pay the
mortgage pay the rent whatever it may be
so that they can emerge on the other
side of this storm without having had to
fold and many of us anticipated long
before the cares Act passed that this
program would need more money I was part
of a group that proposed six hundred
billion dollars for a program like this
recognizing the demand would be huge as
it is on other programs but it's not
just in need of more money it needs some
important fixes which I daresay would
have bipartisan support as well I don't
know if the majority leader saw the
letter just this morning from the
National Restaurant Association here's
what they say the PPP is funded at 349
billion and we expect that lenders will
reach that ceiling shortly
we appreciate the bipartisan calls this
week to provide prompt additional
funding for the program then they go on
to say however equally important equally
important is the need to address the
limitations of the program
that do not recognize the unique and
evolving changes of the restaurant
business cycle and our path to recovery
this is not a Republican group or a
democratic group this is a group that
represents small businesses restaurants
just trying to get by and what they say
to us this morning is yes we do need
additional money we know that but
equally important let's fix some of the
kinks and there are kinks in this
program I got a letter around 12:40 4
a.m. flat this this morning from a small
business owner who had been banking with
Wells Fargo then of course Wells Fargo
hit the cap we thought we had dealt with
that in recent days but he's not sure
he's still going to be able to get that
loan through Wells Fargo and he says
I've also now looked at more than 100
websites of 7a lenders in the greater DC
area and have found none capital letters
none that will accept a PP application
from any small business that did not
bank with them before February 15th 2020
here's some other headlines recent days
Baltimore area small businesses complain
of continuing problems gaining access to
federal lending program nightmare three
small business owners describe process
of applying for PPP coronavirus loans
the journal community bankers frustrated
with PPP roll out another headline this
one from this is another part of the
country
this is PPP loan plan a mess so far for
small businesses writing out coronavirus
crisis billions dispersed through
paycheck protection program question
mark small businesses say not yet wall
street journal' big banks favors certain
customers in 350 billion small business
loan program another article many small
businesses are being shut out of the new
loan program by major banks so mr.
president what we're saying here today
is yes we
no we need more money for this program
many of us predicted this before we
passed the cares Act but for goodness
sakes let's take the opportunity to make
some bipartisan fixes to allow this
program to work better for the very
people it's designed to help small
businesses nonprofits that's what
they're asking us to do so what the
restaurant associations asking us to do
that's what they want us to do and we
could do it probably just as quickly if
the majority leader took a moment to sit
down with us and negotiate that piece
but there are also other major demands
on the system right now that we should
address at this moment and one of them
is something I know we're all hearing
about every day which is to protect the
health care workers on the frontlines
after all if we want to address the
economic crisis we need to address the
health crisis that precipitated that we
need to flatten this virus out bring it
down and that's the best way to get on
the road to economic recovery so I'm
sure all of my colleagues are hearing
from their nurses and doctors and
frontline health care workers about the
urgent need for patient protection
equipment we provided funds in the
original bill but we know today that
that will be exhausted quickly we know
it because we can add up the requests
coming from around the country so let's
address that issue we're hearing from it
every day just just yesterday in our
delegation our Regent senator Cardin and
I and other members of the Maryland
delegation we wrote to FEMA just
yesterday to the administrator of FEMA
and we pointed out that in our most
recent requests Virginia Maryland and
District Columbia receive just a small
percentage of the equipment that we've
requested from FEMA the district
received no hospital ventilators and I
would point out for all of us who are
following this it's predicted that this
area Maryland DC and Virginia is going
to be one of the next hot spots zero
ventilators
zero safety goggles we asked for six
hundred and sixty three thousand gloves
and 1 million over 1 million respirator
masks we got four thousand of one so
that is one problem we need to address
on an urgent basis just as urgently as
we need to address the small business
situation testing my goodness look this
virus we all know got an HR 10-week head
start on us because we were flat-footed
when it came to testing we need a
national rapid testing system so that we
can ensure that people will get the
tests and find out whether the virus
that only not only helps us fight the
virus but it will also help us as we try
to get the country back to work on the
other end of this I would propose that
those are real needs as well and that we
can address those here now in addition
to that as Senator Cardin said we just
spoke to Maryland's governor yesterday
who in addition to being Maryland's
governor is the head of the National
Governors Association and he and
Governor Cuomo have worked very closely
together we have a bipartisan request
from the National Governors Association
to help states and local jurisdictions
we've been on the phone non-stop with
our local officials they are running out
of equipment we've got firefighters who
need help we have emergency responders
who need help all of these requests are
urgent and I believe could be dealt with
on a bipartisan basis if the majority
leader would just take a moment instead
of trying to rush this through we take a
moment we could actually get it done as
we were able to do before with a 96 to
nothing vote so at this time mr.
president I have the amendment of the
desk and I I know people are anxious to
get out of here we we didn't have to
come
at all if it hadn't been for the
decision to try to ram this through I
just want to make that point majority
leader
we knew this wasn't going to get through
so I see people are frustrated and want
to leave but let's get it done and let's
get it done right and let's have another
96 to nothing though here in the United
States Senate so I asked that this
senator the majority leader modified the
request and asked that the amendment of
the desk which is the text of the
interim emergency covin 19 relief act be
agreed to the bill as amendment of his
amended be read a third time and passed
with no further intervening action or
debate is there objection to the
modification abjad objection heard is
there objection objection to the
original request yet the objection is
heard
mr. president Jori leader I would just
repeat all the amendment I offered would
do has changed the amount in the bill
that's all to respond to the obvious
emergency we have with the Paycheck
protection program without a ask
unanimous consent that the Senate stand
adjourned in accordance with the order
of march 26 2024 previously ordered pro
forma sessions without objection under
the previous order the Senate stands
adjourned until 10:00 a.m. on Monday
April the 13th 2029
you